Haha
oni
Kyoichiro Senpai Senator Election Must have wanted to heat up
haha ​​2nd year high
school student  It seems
that Mr. Odaiba was participating in a competition outside the school until just before the new ceremony, and Mr.
Dojima desperately brought
him back.
I received it as a reporter in a wrapper,
Salagadon.  Water
I want to catch up with Cyber-senpai even if just a little, so I'm full of
intention to outsmart him, but that's not the case.
If you lost to me last time, you're probably still upset
There aren't many people who are too sensitive Joichiro Saito I'll
bully you too much Nakamura is a judge
It was the public and it itself
Then he moved forward without fear
Joichiro stepped in and it became a path When Joichiro waved his
knife a new world of taste opened up
Don't be scared, hey, hey,
we'll go anywhere, no matter where
[music]
I'll let you hang on to us No matter where we go